voters in Spain have just under three
hours now to choose a new Parliament
socialist prime minister Pedro Sanchez
called the snap election after his
coalition's poor performance in local
and Regional elections earlier this year
Spaniards now face a choice between the
central left government and a
conservative Coalition which could
include a far-right party for the first
time in decades
I don't want to say if I am optimistic
or not but I do have a good feeling it
is the Spanish people that decide today
the future and progress of the country
so clearly if there is a voice that
needs to be heard today it is theirs the
only thing I can encourage is for people
to vote it really is an important moment
for our country and obviously for our
democracy
is covering the election for us Sonia
you're joining us from Madrid at the
moment look turnout was a talking point
a political talking point ahead of this
election because it's a summertime
election and so not everybody is around
their polling stations you have some
turnout numbers what do we know
well Cyril we do know that there seems
to be a little bit of an increase in
turnout compared to the elections that
took place in 2019. now this could be of
course that more people decided to go to
the polls earlier in the day because it
is as you mentioned the first time that
this kind of election has happened in
summertime since Spain's restoration to
democracy in the late 1970s and of
course we are also in the middle of a
heat wave so that could have galvanized
people's decision to vote sooner rather
than later the temperatures affecting
that but nevertheless there seems to be
a real push to get as many people out to
vote as much as possible from both
left-wing and right-wing parties as it
has been a campaign that has been fought
on ideological grounds
yeah how did that campaign play out
it was quite a big bitterly sort of
divisive campaign with left-wing parties
of course the main party that of the
Prime Minister Pedro Sanchez the
Socialist Workers Party was urging
voters and supporters to uh if if the
country wants to continue on what he
says is the progressive path that the
Socialists have have have taken on then
they the voters that would need to vote
for him uh but of course they have also
made much of the fact that the center
right Party The People's party has been
already going into coalitions at a
regional level with the far-right Vox
party uh perhaps he's using that as a
way of galvanizing voters to vote for
his party as a way of trying to continue
his policies The People's Party
themselves have also fought quite a
bitter campaign as well they've
disdainfully referred to the politics of
of the Prime Minister asan chismo
they've said that now is the time for a
change and that now is also the time for
a restriction in spending they've been
also campaigning on a cut to taxes as
well but of course it's also the ideas
of traditionalism uh stepping step
stepping down on on issues of
immigration as well then perhaps more
culturally conservative Notions as well
which the right wing of the parties here
in Spain are so used to
are you expecting to get results same
day later today
absolutely these results will
within an hour of of the polls closing
uh they come pretty quickly it's an
electoral the system here is actually an
electronic system so they will be coming
pretty soon afterwards and so we'll get
an idea of exactly which party is going
to be that much closer to leading the
nation or if there is going to be a
situation where there will be coalitions
having to be fashioned that will too
become apparent and then of course the
deal making begins as to who and which
party is going to take leadership of
this country all right great stuff San
Diego reporting from Madrid thank you
very much